bismillah hamdullah Salaam alaikum peace
be unto you happy ramadan to everyone
all over the globe thank you for tuning
in to the Dean show and for those who
might be getting a late start you know
that Ramadan has started we all should
be fasting praying doing all the things
that the craters told us to do it's lon
submission to the crater not the
creation that way of life that brings
you peace prosperity in this life and
paradise in the Nexus right so maybe
you're going to lay start but there's
still hope there's still hope and those
who have gotten a fresh start but
there's some bad habits that they've
given up but now you don't want to go
back to them and just be labeled at
Ramadan Muslim and that's the only time
that we implement Islam is during
overtime no we're going to be addressing
these very important issues here in indy
show when we come back don't go anywhere
this is the
this is within you this is the danger
this is the back here on the D show with
shake awesome el Hakim assalamualaikum
shaikh how are you mr. Donilon find that
will ever happen thank you for finding
the time to be with us here on the D
show me now we're here talking about
Ramadan and we know that many people
Muslims now is the time where they
really come back and that's a beautiful
thing that now the mustards are full and
people are starting to commit somewhat
but we have a term called Ramadan
Muslims now that we're gearing we're
going to be gearing towards let's say
the end of Ramadan how can we people how
could people not be labeled as Ramadan
Muslims because obviously there's no
such thing we should be year-round
Muslims so can we start off with some
some tips now that the Ramadan is going
to be ending so we want to keep people
Muslim all year round because the Muslim
is one who submits to the will of Allah
twenty-four-seven not just during
Ramadan solos for tomorrow would you let
me buy you a little devil now you can
look at this in different angles one
angle would be there pessimistic one one
that looks at the ft half of the glass
or of the cup and this was gone by the
English both be on worshipper don't be
someone who only praise and fast and
gives charity on drama bond only do that
throughout the whole year however this
concept sometimes backfires because
Satan is a professional in a delusion
making people deceived and diverse from
the straight path so if you ask me what
your CV how did you my experience of 25
years but we can ask him for his see he
like it goes back to the times of Adam
so the guy he is really experienced and
one of his tricks would be that he was
come to you and say listen that people
are talking about don't be ramadan
worshiper don't only pray and fast and
Rama can do that throughout the whole
year and one with currents innocent I'm
are able to do that provide the season
and it's a blessed season so I'm taking
my advantage of this month and do my
best at it so don't put me down by
Saints you I have to do this to the rest
of the year otherwise it's already
accepted so this is one way of some
people looking at it and it is good when
he encourages others to work with the
remaining 11 must 11 months but it can
backfire now but you've referred to is
extremely correct to those who have a
living spirit and their heart is filled
with a man filled with belief and
conviction they've done so many good
things during the past nights and days
of ramadan that the momentum they have
must continue to the rest of the year
and this is one of the prophets of
working unique ramadan it's like going
to the gym you actually don't go for a
fight every single night but you prepare
for six to seven years of that
particular fight and everything that
you've invested in the previous years
come up and show you you show what it
really takes on that particular night
likewise the month of Ramadan we as
Muslims we excel we try our level best
to do what gets us closer to a lot
though just one say by not seeking and
fasting that's a good way of dieting
it's only that we as Muslims refrain
from lying we refrained from cheating of
course we have to do this not only in
Ramadan throughout the whole year but
the emphasis is far greater and higher
during the month of Ramadan so as
Muslims we excel and we become the
perfect person that a lot of the muslims
may not think that this is possible so
we do different from eating and picked
important in your 18 hours as son of
allegiance to our Lord who commanded us
to do this but we as well refrain from
buying back marketing from cheating we
are so good advisor children to our
neighbors our nests it can we try to
give everything goodbye to our work to
placate ourselves to helping others so
I'm not doing this for the sake of you
or him or anyone else I'm doing it for
the sake of my lord who tells me to
affect my work and to excel in a
character as well we're going to go
ahead and take a break and we're going
to come back with more talking about
Ramadan and here you can stay on track
all year round not just from a Dan here
on the Dean show with Sheikh awesome el
Hakim we'll be right back so pull who
Allah say he allows one God is one the
maker America exactly a lot who's
somewhat lost self-sufficient he doesn't
need food or drink he doesn't need to
rest on the seventh day ok I really had
a problem with that even before I knew
anything about a slump God resting
sounds like a week guy yeah lamb ya lit
well I'm you let he begets not he
doesn't have any children nor was he a
child or born of anything
well I'm yahoo local I and there is
nothing called equal or comparable to
him at all nobody nothing Jesus nobody
nobody is comparable to the crater
nothing yeah and that right there was in
his essence what I believe naturally
you
back here on the D show and we're trying
to keep you in the Ramadan spirit all
year round tell us Jake if now you can
leave off and we see this is a good
thing people are conscious now during
this month of their creator and many
have left off the alcohol they left off
smoking they've left our fornicating
because they're like you know what I'm
going to commit for these 30 days now if
you can commit for these 30 days isn't
this a prove to yourself that you can
commit the whole year round shouldn't
you be able to Oh what is able to do
this but remember as Muslims we believe
that during the holy month and the noble
month of Ramadan the Masters of gin and
the Devils are chained so they would not
reach but they usually are able and
capable of teaching so amount of sin by
evil during the month of Ramadan is
drastically reduced and this is visible
you can see that everywhere to have in
Muslim and non-muslim world with great
imagine the challenges after the month
Ramadan has concluded then the whole and
you guys say the state all hell breaks
loose so everything is Wow everything is
pooping man and the devil say listen
we've been off duty for about a month
and we have to make over time to make up
for what was boss so the petition is
more and the Muslim suffers even more
and more I'd ramadan is over I'm going
back to square one but the thing is that
with the graceful ladoja Muslim is
nothing back to square one he's always
progressing so last year in Roma Bahn he
was like in level 10 today in Ramadan
with mothers over he's a limited play
five so every Ramadan he is building up
he is picking up momentum he is visiting
his stamina and his you know his decide
to live by
are getting bigger and bigger and his
bench pressing more and more
economically and a regarding his email
so completely not those who've tasted
the sweetness of work done they will
continue on maintaining fasting month to
date on monday the surge this for
example couple of days a week doesn't do
you any harm and by also maintaining
fortune a portion of night prayers so
they pray like half an hour an hour
every night this is the connection
between themselves and their lord you
don't have to put two actor and see like
forgive me Father for I have sinned no
you're going straight to Allah soldier
and then all my lord o creator of the
heavens and the earth absent and I'm
here to cleanse my sins and provide my
heart they continue to give to charity
and have they learned Muslims are the
biggest honors and spenders when it
comes to charity so feeding the poor and
the destitute and giving shelter to the
orphanage that is the dolphins and
building orphanages a worldwide you can
contribute with pennies and nickels and
dimes you don't have to pay hundreds and
thousands of millions of dollars so if
you do you can on the right track but if
you don't never underestimate think that
is possible that would get the closer to
Allah and elevate your status in
paradise so the sky is the limit you
aced it how it feels to be an obedient
servant of Allah of God though money and
don't wait and throw away this pride
dignity and are that you have gained
because of your being a servant to Allah
so just do an odd odd don't just wait
keep it up and a Santa what if someone
tells you now have you heard this is a
look you just told me that you know
Shaitaan is locked up during Ramadan so
now he's unlocked so I have
excuse now to let all hell break loose
what would you say to this person well
this is a test listen I'm in concert not
for easy right model jet delisted 70 or
80 years on earth to be tested and the
results and will be no on the day
judgment and it's either paradise for
eternity or a fraternity and if you
compare apples to apples and there's no
comparison none whatsoever so the total
service that's free but you still have
the backing of a mother's they will just
do you usurp have the leaf that's
concrete and solved in your heart and
with the people you have the backing of
the angels if you show a lot i'll just
get acidity and that you want surveyed a
lot of almighty will provide that for
you and will help you obtain that with
minimal effort beautiful beautiful
advice shake we're going to take a break
and come back to wrap it up here on the
D show don't go anywhere jihad often
mistranslated as holy war the word jihad
means to struggle Islam does not preach
violence it does not preach vicious holy
war it certainly does not condone terror
and suicide bombing Islam preaches
compassion tolerance and justice find
the truth about Islam call toll-free 877
why Islam
back here on the D show and again thank
you sure you're finding the time to be
with us to answer these questions that
are in the minds of the people now for
the person we reach out to a lot of not
yet Muslims and many we know that
according to the guinness book of world
records that Islam is the
fastest-growing way of life in the world
and so many people are coming to Islam
and so much so many of the old-time
Muslims now are also coming back to the
Dean so for the person now he's watching
the Dean show she's watching the D show
and let's say she's been a little or
he's been a little accident oh and
they've already let some of these days
pass by of Ramadan they haven't been
fasting is it too late if right now they
swatching addy show and you know they
got encouraged by you know the month of
Ramadan they want to get into the spirit
but they're like you know what I already
missed 10 days of Ramadan is it too late
for me well the good news is that la is
most merciful Allah those are never
protects people never turned them down
whoever comes to Allah Almighty seeking
his forgiveness repenting to Allah
exposing his deep remorse and showing
sincerity Allah Almighty would not only
forgive his sense because this is but we
will have expected if you go to someone
and ask for forgiveness the kindest
person on earth would probably give you
not a large order Allah is not like that
lies unlike anything you know up a lot
of old monkey if you come to him seeking
assertiveness and you put it so can
express your sincere and deep remorse
Allah Almighty would forgive you since
not only that he would change the sense
to good deeds so it has a million bats
it bad deeds and a million Sims but you
come as forgiveness and i'll give you he
turns them into a million good deeds so
it's never too late the issue is it is
Satan who's we spoke about the CD
earlier that is a
so whenever you want to repent this is
why now let's watch CSI miami for
example and then repent afterwards by
now let's watch hangover 3 then
inshallah allah is forgiving let's go
and have let me finish this bottle and
then they call it acquit so he always
makes you delay asking a lot of
forgiveness to delay repenting to Allah
is gorgeous and before you know it it's
too late and you die without repenting
never dig it and always be on top of it
if you make a sin of all its fact that
life was forgiving and merciful see if
it forgiveness as per his mercy repent
and he will gig to understand shaker in
the last minute that we have can you
give us some closing comments advice and
at the end wish everybody a happy
ramadan and a happy eid well it is
extremely important to know at one part
of the significance of ramadan is a
unity among muslims muslims worldwide
where they do inside here whether you're
in Alaska within your hawaii i hope the
people hawaii faster now but family you
are my friend we're all fasting it's the
same month for all of us all of us tins
they face the same spot in prayer five
times a day man if you are from China or
you to confront this the u.s. we all
meet in SE assalamualaikum we face the
same direction in prayer fastest a month
so it is son of unity after ama on the
unity chicken in you and we'll shoot the
bay united thank you so much shake thank
you so much for being with us may Allah
bless you with the wonderful Ramadan and
if we don't see you again and may you
have after the end of a wonderful eid at
the end of it all and may allah accept
all your deeds and ever and all of ours
army be there
I thank you so much shake and I hope
that you got to benefit I surely did
with the great advice we know that the
Creator Allah is the most loving the
most merciful jesus prayed to him he
didn't pray to himself Moses Abraham and
all the other messages including
Mohammad being the last they all faceted
they prayed and they did all of these
things because out of the love for their
creator and the crater loves you that's
why he's ordained these things and even
if you're getting a late start get
started do a 180 turn back to the most
loving the most forgiving and start
fasting start fasting right away
tomorrow and start to beseech your
Creator for earnestly for the help to
help you stay committed throughout the
rest of Ramadan and you'll see that
peace and tranquility it'll be a
struggle everything that's worth
something is a struggle so paradise you
got to struggle for it but we got to get
there because we're going to leave this
life behind pretty soon we're going to
be saying bye-bye and what sad state
would it be if we just ignore it all of
these signs if we ignored our
responsibilities in this life so it's
Ramadan now for those people who have
also been fasting and when it ends
please let's try not to go back to the
bad behavior may be many people have
given up alcohol they've given up
gambling fornicate and all these other
things give it up totally if you can
give it up for the whole month of
Ramadan continue on strive and struggle
all the way to the end we know that the
Jenna as the last final messenger said
is surrounded by undesirable things and
the Hellfire is surrounded by desirable
things right so if you want to go ahead
and get that PhD or you want to get that
diploma you have to study you have to
work hard these are undesirable things
for a lot of people but ultimate success
lies after you achieve this but now to
cut class to skip school to go to the
club to sleep in be late for work I mean
that's just following your desires
that's not difficult at all so to get to
paradise it requires effort it requires
work and at the end you got paradise you
got Jenna but now following your lusts
and desires you sleep in late you're
going to get soonerlater fired from work
right you keep cutting class you're
going to get dropped you're going to get
kicked out of school
we ignore our responsibilities that
Allah has told us to do at the end what
do we got waiting for us there's Jenna
and then there's a flip side it's a
Hellfire many of us it's there we can't
imagine ourselves being in that place
but it's a place that many will end up
in so now is the time count the
blessings that Allah has given you be
thankful and grateful I'm a gratitude
and love for your maker ponder over it
motivate you to be the bestest from a
doubt and may carry on all year round so
at the end when we die we've been
implementing Islam submission did it
create an out the creation and doing
good being good living a good righteous
like we're going to make mistakes but
allows the most loving and forgiving
turn back to him each and every time you
make a mistake but as long as you've got
the connection you dialed up direct and
you're asking him forgiveness for
guidance then this is the right way and
we hope that you stay in touch with us
continue to watch the Dean show we send
our salaams to all those happy ramadan
to everyone all over the world may have
a blessed Eid and continue to follow us
on the facebook twitter sheriff shows
and contribute to the Dean show help us
in doing this noble cause of educating
the world on the most misunderstood way
of life yet the fastest-growing way of
life in the world Islam that's right it
continues to grow each and every day
because it's simple it's believable and
we've got the proof that one needs to
know that is it indeed not man-made but
is it deed by the one who made us the
one creator so read the Quran call us a
1-800 662 Islam we'll see you next time
until then peace be unto you come on now
so ladies and gents brothers and sisters
contribute to the cause contribute
towards the Dawa the education of
humanity and you inshallah we'll have a
ticket by the permission of Allah when
you're working for the Dean supporting a
D on the their judgement all that all
those good deeds will be waiting for you
inshallah we can get to Jenna